Beautiful wife
We've been running into fanseverywhere
we go lately.
yes
Recently in Singapore
That airport
We also met
a young fan
Seeing us so happy
want to take a photo with us, right?
yes
More and more
young people
often watch our videos
But I think
You're becoming more and more special.
ha?
Fans keep praising your hair
saying it's getting more and more beautiful.
Excuse me
Hu Naiwen Course Starts
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Top 5 Health Topics in 2025
Come on!
The editor has compiled a special collection
The 5 health topics
our channel's fans
are most concerned about this year
Beautiful wife, guess what?
Our fans
What topic are most concerned about?
If you guess the first place correctly
I will give you a prize.
Eyes, eyes!
Everyone is on their phones every day
The one sweeping the floor
you tell me
Which topic might be number one?
I guess it must be from sleeping.
Because Taiwanese people
consume over 400 million sleeping pills every year.
How scary!
You guess too.
Leave a message and tell us
Come on, let's reveal the 5th place!
5th place is
hypertension
People with hypertension
You absolutely must watch this video.
We have linked these five videos.
They're all in the information section.
What is the theme of the 4th place?
It's kidney dialysis, or washing the kidneys.
It has been viewed 840,000 times.
Taiwan Dialysis
No.1 in the world
Don't want to do dialysis
What are the 3 behaviors that damage the kidneys?
Don't do it again.
I know
Love using pain relief patches
love bubble tea
tastes very salty
You're amazing! You got them all right!
It's nothing.
The top 3 are about to be revealed.
Beautiful wife
You reveal the answer, okay?
Please come
3rd place is
knee issues
It has been viewed 900,000 times.
A lot of people are watching it.
Give you a round of applause for encouragement!
The second place is
Let me reveal how fun it is!
It's a problem for people in their 50s and 60s.
Poor sleep
It was viewed by 2.92 million people.
Students on night shift
Do you remember
what kind of tea I taught you to drink?
Have a cup of chrysanthemum tea
Protect your liver
Reduce the harm of staying up late
What was the theme of number one?
Come, please lift it up and take a look.
What is it?
Eye
Eye health
It has already reached 5 million views.
Thank you for your support.
And you guessed right, okay.
Here, I'll give you one right away.
The acupoints for preventing presbyopia are called
Yǎng lǎo acupoint (transliteration)
This acupoint
It can relieve eye fatigue.
It can delay aging
Where is the Yǎng lǎo acupoint (transliteration)?
On the back of the arm
One inch above the wrist crease
The depression between the ulna and radius
You usually take the bus or the MRT
Whenever you have time
Like me, press it.
Just press it like that.
Right here on the bone
Like this
Turn your hand slightly like this
This place is
Beautiful lady, you're right.
I want to give you a gift
Heart-shaped flowers
Is that all?
I'm a very easy-going person.
I’ll give you a casualflower
flower
That's how you show sincerity.
I like these kind of casual flowers
That's great, take a look.
High blood pressure
One acupoint to lower blood pressure and relieve chest tightness
During Chinese New Year
Eat big fish and meat, drink alcohol
Worried about your blood pressure spike?
There's an acupoint that's very effective for lowering blood pressure.
hands out
There is an acupoint here.
It is called shén mén (transliteration) acupoint
Learn it right away
The shén mén (transliteration)acupoint is located here.
The horizontal lines on this wrist
Between the little finger and the ring finger
Intersection of this line
It is called shén mén (transliteration)acupoint
Press this acupoint
Does it feel a little sour and tingly?
That means you pressed right place.
You press gently
Don't use too much force.
This acupoint can
Calm the mind and stabilize the will
Do you have palpitations or chest tightness?
A gentle press will provide relief.
I don't have high blood pressure, high cholesterol, or high blood sugar.
How did i do that?
Avoid these 3 types of food
I am in my 70s, almost 80 years old.
No problems with the three highs (high blood pressure, high blood sugar, and high cholesterol)
Three types of food to eat less of
The first type of food that is too salty
Hot pot soup, sausage, cured meat
I'm telling you
I have a diet rule
I just don't drink the hot pot soup.
Whether it's eating pickled cabbage and pork hot pot
Kimchi hot pot or spicy hot pot
I usually
Eat the ingredients but don't drink the soup
Everyone eats hot pot
Everyone drink hot pot soup
All its essence is in...
This is the essence.
The soup was delicious.
However,
the soup has a particularly high sodium content.
And that one was very salty.
And drinking too much
It can easily cause blood pressure, blood sugar, and blood lipids to spike
leading to the "three highs" (high blood pressure, high blood sugar, and high cholesterol).
There's also a fourth high: high uric acid.
High uric acid levels can lead to gout.
That gout is making you suffer.
Good, you must eat this during Chinese New Year.
Grilled sausages and stir-fried cured meat are two types of food.
It is high in salt and high in fat.
There is also added nitrite.
Nitrites are classified as a Group 1 carcinogen
by the World Health Organization.
People with high blood pressure, high blood sugar, and high cholesterol should remind you.
Don't eat too much.
Eating too much caused my blood pressure and blood lipids
to spike.
Celebrate the New Year a bit
Like sausage
We eat 3 or 4 pieces
It's not like I'm eating 3 or 4 strips.
It shouldn't matter.
certainly
Okay, eating 3 or 4 slices is fine.
Eating happily leads to a sense of happiness, right?
What if it's too delicious?
You couldn't hold back for a moment.
Eat some more
couldn't help it for a moment.
What to do if you eat too much
Eat a fruit
It can remove nitrites
Guava is very good.
I'll tell you to buy some guavas.
A guava after a meal
Guava contains Vitamin C
Able to neutralize
Nitrite in 18 sausages
Isn't it amazing?
Eating guava can help relieve it.
That's good.
Second, starch, glutinous rice type food
They have a high glycemic index
Eat a bowl
Blood sugar instantly went up like a roller coaster.
People with diabetes must be patient.
The portion size must be controlled.
The third type of food is...
High-fat dishes
Like Dongpo pork, pork hock, roast duck
And those fried until golden and crispy
Crispy food
People with high blood pressure, high cholesterol, or high blood sugar should eat less of this.
So that blood lipids won't rise.
Protect your heart and lungs in winter
One acupoint to stabilize your heartbeat
Beautiful wife, do you know?
Taiwan in 2024
The top three deadliest diseases
These are the three types.
Cancer, heart disease, pneumonia
A cold winter
You need to pay more attention to your heart
and lung health.
Some fans said
Heart discomfort, myocardial infarction
Are there any first aid methods?
Recommend you an emergency acupoint
What should it be called?
I often say
Yáng xī (transliteration) acupoint is located in this place.
People with high blood pressure
You can press it down.
Helps regulate your heart rate and lower blood pressure
breathing has also improved.
Where is Yáng xī (transliteration) acupoint located?
The back of the thumb
On the wrist
There is a very big hole
This cave is called Yáng xī (transliteration) acupoint
When pressed down
You will feel a little sore
It even brings a slightly tingling feeling
Then you pressed the right button.
Sometimes the chest feels tight
Sometimes heart races.
Pressing Yáng xī (transliteration)acupoint
Pressing it
will gradually relieve the discomfort.
This acupoint is on the hand.
It's very convenient to press
You must remember this!
Here are some health keywords for you in 2026.
Healthier heart and lungs
In the new year
I'll give you two words
Take care of your heart and lungs
Leap and stillness
Leap means to jump or leap.
The meaning of 'get moving
Want to take good care of your heart and lungs
You just have to get moving
People with heart problems
You can do some low-intensity exercises
Both brisk walking and jogging are good.
Promote blood circulation
What about people with weak lungs?
You can eat
White food
White radish, white fungus, yam
Make your lungs healthier
quiet
It has the meaning of stopping and stabilizing.
When your heart is calm
Only then can the Qi and blood of the five internal organs flow smoothly.
Only then can the body and mind be naturally healthy.
You can do it through meditation.
Or listen to relaxing music
Come and calm your mind
I also thought of something else.
We go to see
Shen Yun every year!
Oh, Shen Yun Performing Arts. Yes, that's right.
I feel like every time I finish watching,
my soul is cleansed
Very satisfied
I also recommend you go see it!
Healing the soul with art
More than just relieving stress
It can also improve breathing
Make your heart and lungs healthier
The secrets to health from birth
to 100 years old
You said it could
Children and adults
The secret to health
From age 0 to 90
What is it?
Do you still remember this sentence?
Nèi shāng pí wèi bǎi bìng yóu shēng (transliteration)
remember
You are saying
The source of many diseases
It all starts with spleen deficiency.
Not bad, not bad
Look!
Yī jiā lǐ dōng yuán zài jīn yuán shí dài (transliteration)
already knew the importance of the spleen and stomach
The spleen and stomach transform the food you eat
into
qi and blood
to supply the liver, heart, lungs, kidneys, etc.
When the spleen and stomach are weak
The supply of qi and blood cannot keep up.
All the internal organs
Lack of nutrients delivered by the spleen and stomach
That would naturally make the body
more prone to problems.
How to nourish your spleen and stomach?
Avoid doing things that harm your spleen and stomach.
First
Eat less or not eat
sashimi
Iced drinks and lettuce salad
Fried chicken and French fries
Those strong-flavored foods
Don't eat too much.
Eat too much
Secondly, the spleen
corresponds to yellow foods.
Eat millet, pumpkin, lotus seeds, etc.
It can nourish the spleen and stomach
Eat at a certain time
Avoid staying up late
Give your spleen and stomach enough time to rest
Therefore, nourishing the spleen and stomach is the key secret.
Take good care of your spleen and stomach
You will receive these 5 gifts
1. Sleep soundly at night and feel refreshed in the morning
2. Abundant Qi and Blood, Full of Vitality
3. Strong immunity
It also keeps you away from illnesses such as colds.
4. Bright eyes, dry and tired
Hehe, all of them are OUT!
5. Smooth metabolism and good digestion.
People who take good care of their spleen and stomach
You'll find yourself
looking younger and younger.
New Year Plans for the Channel
New Year
We have two new plans
I want to share with everyone
First plan
It was our team's editor
Xiaofen, who joined.
It's Xiaofen next to me.
Say hello to everyone!
Hello everyone
Thank you so much for your support.
I will appear on this channel in the future.
Bringing you more fun
and practical health content
Please continue to support us.
Thanks
Second plan
We will also invite
More physicians and experts joined
Let's talk about health
Answer your questions
Finally, wish everyone a happy new year.
Horses treading on auspicious clouds bring good fortune.
Golden Horse Brings Good Fortune
Happy New Year
Happy New Year everyone!
Dear fans
We have launched the membership channel.
If you agree with my promotion of Traditional Chinese Medicine
The concept of taking care of one's own health
Small monthly donations are welcome.
It only costs the price of two cups of coffee!
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you by my side
Only then can we go further.
Thank you so much!